色自体は有の状態です
いわゆる受 仏教では受の状態というんですね
生受滅に分けたのはそういうわけなんです
色の生受滅の三段階目では
受の一切で目に触れると
ですから訳があって あの刹那を三つに分けちゃったんです
一刹那も生受滅の 滅の三刹那だよと
そうすると色も色なりに十七刹那生きているんだと
そこで一刹那が生と一刹那が滅で
十五の刹那が受だと で
言ってるんです ですから
もうヨーロッパ的な西洋的な波の物理論に別にあっても
あてはまらないことで
それどうでもいいことなんです
アビダンマにとっては
一応一刹那は生まれる刹那
それから二から十六番目まで受の刹那
それから十七番目で滅と
消えちゃうと そこで目にこの色が触れると
その色の素粒子がこの受の間では触れるんですね
存在している間だけは
そのところはエネルギーのピークのところだから
触れてわかっちゃうんですね
だからエネルギーはポジティブな状態でないと触れないんです
ネガティブな状態でわからないんですね
まあ一応難しいんだったらまだまだ何回も説明しますけど
それほど難しくはないと思いますが
そこでこの極大対象というのは
色が生まれたと 目に見える何か形が現れたと
現れる瞬間は誰にも見えない
見えるならば現れた瞬間からなんですね
そこで消える瞬間も見えない
現れる瞬間も見えないし
消える瞬間も見えないし
見えるのは受の時間だけ
現れて存在している時間だけ見えると
そこである目に見える色があって
それは現れた 現れた瞬間で何もエネルギーを持っていないんだから
目を刺激するエネルギーは
現れた瞬間で 次の瞬間で色は色として存在しているんだから
エネルギーを持ってるんですね
それで我々の目を刺激するんです
心 心は有分の状態にいるんです
我々外から何も情報はない
だから自分だけでただ回転しているんです
それは有分心というんですね
パーリ語でバワンディチットというんですね
心は有分心なんですね
心にはいつでも軸回転できるんだから
自分で自分を認識してずっと回転しているんですね
だから輪廻っていうのは
まあずっと輪廻する もうどうしようもないんです
輪廻はもう止まることはもうすっごい難しくて
もうそれこそ世の中で一番難しいこと
これ基本的なエネルギーだから
もう心っていうのは 心は自分で回転する
物質よりも誰よりもつかみにくいもので
だからまあそれこそ確かなんですね
世の中で 輪廻するっていうことは
心は回転するっていうこと
で 我々にとってはこの何も見るものも聞くものも何もない
なくても 命として心は自分で回転しながらいるので
でも何も知らない 何も認識していない
ただ有分心だけ生まれて消えて
生まれて消えて 生まれて消えてと
我々なんか なんとなく足踏み状態で次の行動に待っているようなものなんです
次の号令が来るまで足踏みをしながらいると
心はいつでも生滅 生滅
生滅しながら ずっと生滅ばっかり繰り返しているんです
それで目を通って そこを外の世界にもう何か見るものが
絵が現れたんだと 現れた瞬間ではわかりませんだけど
次の瞬間からこの目を通って心にそれぶつかっちゃうんです
エネルギーが ぶつかっちゃうと
この有分心やってる心がこの一回ぶつかると
いわゆる心は瞬間瞬間変化しますから
心がこの有分心の心に色の二番目のシャナの時触れるでしょ
触れたらこの有分身が次に死んじゃうんです
死んで次の有分身が生まれるんです
その二番目の有分身にも
この三番目のセツナの刺激がまた触れちゃう
それで心の流れがどんどん変わっちゃうんですね
心っていうのはいつでもあの今の心はちょっと前の心から影響を与える受けるんですね
だから全くの波の法則で
それだから私の今の瞬間の心の状態は
次の瞬間の心の状態に確実に影響を与えるのです
ですから 一番目の有分身は何も知らないで有分ばっかしやっていたんだけど
いきなり何か触れちゃったと
触れたらちょっとわずかな触れたという変化が起こる
また二回もまた同じものを触れちゃうと
それまた変化しちゃって有分は消えちゃうんですね
大体三回目ぐらいになっちゃうと
もう有分消えちゃうんです
じゃあ認識ですよ なんか情報あるんだと
もう情報あるっていうことがわかっちゃうんですね
そこで情報は目を通って入っちゃったんだから
三回目 四回目の有分身が生まれません
四回目にはあの五門陰転パンチャドゥーラワッジャナという心が生まれちゃうんです
どこですかと探す心なんです
いわゆる有分身が新しい心に生まれ変わっちゃう
五門陰転という心が生まれちゃう
ここまでですから このパンチャドゥーラワッジャナチッテ
いわゆる五門陰転という心は
あの別に そんなに大した心ではないんだけど
このその移動は忘れて物事を考えないとこれわからないんですね
やっぱり難しい その辺で難しいんです
この物体の移動を忘れて
物体の存在というところから思考を働かせないと
だから まあ一応物体で考える
心という物体があるんだと
大きな球のようなもの
それはもう何もことなく
まあ泡のように 次から次と同じ形の泡が出ているんだと
それで外からちょっとした影響入っちゃうんだと
わずかな空気でもいいし
わずかな色でもいいし
入っちゃうとこの同じ一箇所に泡が現れて弾けて
次の泡が出て弾けて 次の泡が弾けて
外は何もない場合は いくら見ていたっても全く
同じ型の泡が出てはじけて出てはじけて出てはじけていくんです
そこはジーと同じ泡だから
わずかに外から何かちょっと
例えばほんのちょっと空気を与えてあげると
それでどうなるかというと
次の泡がちょっと変化して生まれちゃうんです
それ次の泡がまた変化して生まれるんです
それから生まれる生まれる泡がある一定の形をとって生まれちゃうんですね
そこでまたその空気を止まってもらう
止まってもらったら この一定の変化した泡がまた元に戻って
また元の泡が出てはじけて泡が出てはじけて
それで空気ではなくて
ほんのわずか光を与えてみると
そうするときっと光を与えた瞬間
次に出てくる泡がその光の色をとったりする
そういうふうに ある一箇所で認識というものが生まれて消えて生まれて消えて生まれて消えていっちゃうんです
移動するんじゃなくて
そこでその有分身がずっと有分が一つの分が消えたら次の分生まれる
その分消えたら次の分が生まれる
そこで体というのでっかいものだから
目から情報が触れたと
いわゆるそこ物質の世界でどうせエネルギーはぶつかり合ってますから
そこを光がぶつかった途端
この有分身の泡が次に消えちゃう
有分身はもう二度と出てこない
その代わりに五蘊因縁という泡が生まれちゃうんです
この五蘊因縁という泡が
このどこから この 何て言いますか
この情報が入ったかと
どこから自分の落ち着いた状態
こんな静かに来たなというふうな感じで
心は有分身が本当は情報を欲しくて欲しくているんです
なぜならば 有分身だけの波はそんな激しくないんですね
刺激はないんです 刺激はいっぱい入れといた方が永久的にこれにはもう消滅戦ができるんですね
ですから心はどうしても刺激を探して探しているんです
何もない時は有分になっちゃうんです
なって足を踏みながらいるんです
情報が入っちゃうとすごい気持ちよく
すぐもう有分身が生まれちゃう
有分身じゃなくて五蘊因縁身という心が生まれる
五蘊因縁という泡が生まれると
五蘊因縁もほぼ有分身に似ているもんなんですけどね
ちょっと心象が違う だから心象だけ違うんだからね
九十八ページにそれからの説明出てくるんです
タッサーナンバランタンエバルーパンパッサンタンチャッコウィンヤーナンサンパティッチャナンサンチッタンサンティーレヤーマナンサンティーラナチッタンオワッハッテンタンオッチャッパナチッタン
それでこのこういう風になるんですね
で この五蘊因縁の泡が生まれたと
次にこれは目から入った情報ですというならば
五蘊因縁の次にチャッコウィンヤーナという泡になって
いわゆる眼識という目から入ったものだから
この有分身の代わりに五蘊因縁身の代わりに眼識チャッコウィンヤーナっていうものが心が生まれる
心は一つ泡が一つしかない
で 眼識っていうものが生まれちゃう
眼識生まれるのはその対象を取ってなんで対象そこにないと心の変化は起こりません
だから泡と泡は変化するのは外からずっと影響を与えている時だけなんですね
例えば 泡がちょっと横長に横に長くしたければ
ある方向からちょっと空気を吹いてあげなくちゃいけないんです
だから一定の速さでずっと空気を振っておくと
次から次へ出るどんな泡でもある一定の方向へ曲がっているんですね
そこで空気が止まった瞬間
また泡の状態形が元に戻ししまっちゃうんですね
例えば泡が赤くしたければ
ずっと赤い光を与えておかなくちゃいけない
それでそれからはもう全部泡が赤い
それで赤い光が消しちゃったら
泡がまた元の色に戻っちゃう
そういう風にこの五蘊因縁は見える絵はなかったら生まれませんし
眼識もチャッコウィンヤーナも見える絵がなかったら生まれませんし
それでチャッコウィンヤーナが生まれたと
いわゆるこれは目に入るべき目で認識する情報だと
もう決めたんですね 決めたんじゃなくて
そうなっちゃったんですね
目で認識しちゃった そこで目で認識してそれで終わらない
まだあの色があの見た絵がまだいるんですね
明日ならば寿命長いんだから
次にサンパティッチャナ
サンパティッチャナという心が生まれる
領受心 領受心っていうのは
まあ心はその受け入れる
いわゆる目から入った情報の方向へ行ってしまう
刺激があっちあります
そこに行こうと なんかあの磁石みたいな感じで
そっち行こうとも引かれちゃうんですね
だからこのゲンニビ精神というのは
なんかあっちこっちからなんか磁石みたいなもので
心はどっちあっちこっちずっと引かれっぱなしなんです
だから心はもう認識したいんです
いつでも刺激を受けたい
それでもう色が入る ルーパですね
ルーパが入っていて この用語のぐちゃぐちゃで説明しにくいんだけど
すごい簡単なんですね
覚悟を決めてパーリ語の用語を使うか
もうどっちかにということでないと
ですから このまあとにかく日本の用語で曖昧でも英語の対を使ってもいいしね
で まあ英語ではビジュアルオブジェクトさんですね
見えるオブジェクト対象だからビジュアルオブジェクトあればビジュアルオブジェクトというものはもうずっと 17 セツナは生きているんですね
だから 17 セツナ間あり
まあ厳密に言えば 15 セツナ間は影響を与えちゃうんですね
そこで終わっちゃうんです
ですから 心はまずまあ 2番目は何もしません
知らない でもちょっとなんかおかしいと知っていて
それでもう 3番目ぐらいになっちゃうと
それで消えちゃって 五門陰転が生まれて
それからチャックインナーが生まれる
アイコンシャスネスというもう眼識というものが生まれちゃうんですね
それでまたこのビジュアルオブジェクトというこの式が
ルーパがまだいるんですね
同じルーパがいるんだから
次にそこらの方向へ決めようと
もう受け入れちゃうんですね
その対象 あれはなんかこの磁石で磁石が来たんだから
そちらに行こうというふうに引かれたような感じなんです
次にこのサンティーラナという心が生まれる
これ 須弥道心というんですね
このサンティーラナという心が須弥道心が生まれたら
次に確定心という心が生まれるのです
これ 順番は決まってるんです
五門陰転 ゲンニビ精神の色
眼識 鼻識 なんとかなんとか
それから領受心 それから須弥道心
それから確定心 もう決まってる
その順番 いわゆるこの心の波が変わらなくちゃいけない
この波はどのように変わるかっていうことはもう決まってるもんなんです
色が入ったら まあまず受け入れる
それからそこに傾く それからもう一応何者かとそこでもう決めてしまうというか
この色見たものでね 見たものになってしまうというかね
もう染めてしまうというふうな状態になっちゃうんですね
ついてしまう 磁石でわかりやすい
例えば一つの磁石があって
もうぶら下がってるもう一つ磁石があるんだと
一つの磁石をぶら下がっておく
糸で もう一つの磁石はもうそこら辺近寄って持ってくると
そうすると あの磁石はさっとその方向へ行って定着してしまっちゃうんですね
ですから この三十六 まあ糸でぶら下がってる磁石だったら
糸が行けるどんな方向でもその磁石が曲がっていくでしょうに
前から行ったら前に磁石が飛んでいっちゃうし
後ろから出したら後ろに飛んでいっちゃうし
ちょっと上から出しちゃったら糸を曲がってね
上へ行ってそこでつけちゃうし
このつけるところ 磁石が次の外の磁石のつけるところはもう確定心という風になっちゃうんですね
それから問題なんですけど
たとえからえくうなってんさかまわちゃらじゃわねえそうやん
キンチラッダッパッチャやん
えぶいえにさったかっくんジャワティ
それからこのジャワのチッタという心が生まれるんです
ジャワナっていうのはこっち
即興という言葉が書いてますけど
走るという意味なんですね
走るという意味もあります
エネルギーという意味もあります
ジャワっていうのはこのスタミナなんですね
ですから 即興という風に
ジャワの英語は何でしたっけ
ジャワナという言葉がこの英訳してないんです
これもジャワナという言葉を使ってるんですね
アビダンマを書いた昔の先生方は
ジャワナっていうのは走るという意味で考えてるんですね
で まあエネルギーなんですね
スタミナという意味なんですね
ですから 即興と言えばどういう意味ですかね
即興という言葉の中にそういう意味が入ってますかね
うん いわゆるこの あの
なんのことなく 自然的に
この泡に 泡に例えてみると
ある穴があって そこから泡が一つ二つ
一つ消えて 次のものが出るような感じで
心が一つ それから次の心
次の心と泡のように出てくるんです
そこでこの外からなんとかちょっとした影響入ったというと
そこら辺にその泡がちょっと決まってる
変化は起こっちゃうんですね
それはもう五蘊印頓と因典と
それからそれから認識の心とサンパティッチナサンティーラナゴッタパナという順番で生まれるんですね
で それからこの確定しました
もう心がこれやと で心が望んでいたこの認識
刺激を受けちゃったんですね
それでもうスタミナみたいな心が七つぐらいさーっと生まれるんです
それすごく力強い もうはっきりした心なんです
寝ている心じゃないんです
ジャヴァナっていうのはすごい力強くて
もうエネルギーある心なんですね
それはどういうジャヴァナって
もうスタミナの心というと
これはどれぐらいあります？えーと
エクーナ エクーナテンさん
29種類の心があるんですね
あの 29のジャヴァナ心は 89の中でどんなどんな心かと
もう今すでに暗記していないと
まあ理解に苦しみますけどね
だからチャートでもあるならば
チャートでジャヴァナ心は
即行心はどこにどこにあるものかと見てください
この 29のジャヴァナ
12種類の不善心 それから8種類の善心
それから8種類の唯作心
で28 次におそらく正気心だと思います
そうすると 29の欲界の即行心
あのいろいろチャートはまあ
あのテキストの中にもそれなりのチャートはありますからね
見てください 欲界 欲界っていうのはゲンリビ出身の世界
ゲンリビ出身の世界の中で 54種類の心しか生まれませんし
で その中で 29種類の心が即行の働きはします
いわゆるスタミナ エネルギーを蓄積する
溜まる 積もる仕事をします
あれ テキストではどんなページですかね
89ページ うん そこでこの 29種類の 29種類の心の中で一つだけ
このスタミナの機能するんです
29をまとめるわけじゃないんです
で 7回しか心が生まれます
いわゆるこの また泡の例に戻りますけど
ある一つの穴から泡一つ一つ生まれてくる
一つずつ生まれてくるならば
このスタミナ的な強い泡も七つしか生まれません
それまた形は決まってるんです
なぜならば 泡が変化したのは外の影響だから
いい加減に変化することはできませんし
ですから それなりに決まってる心が生まれる
こういうことわかりやすくすれば
例えば目に何か触れたと
触れた対象が見て 私は怒ったと
見たところで怒った場合は不善心の怒りの心ドーサチッタなんですね
その場合は七つのドーサチッタ
親根心が七つ生まれるんです
だから ある人がその私ともう一人が同じものを見たんだと
その人が笑ったと 喜んだと
面白いものだと こっちはこちらは腹が立ってるのに
向こうが面白いものだと笑ってるんだと
その人はその対象に惹かれてるんですね
その人の場合は 八種類の欲の心の中から一つ即行心として七つ生まれるんです
一つ七回生まれるんです
それ即行心と言うんですね
同じものが七回  そう  そして変わることない
変わることない 即行心はいつでも一つの心
七回生まれる だから二十九から一つ選ぶ
選んでそれは七回生滅回転する
いわゆる泡の場合は泡が七回
ある一定の形の泡が七回生まれる
七回でもうあの対象の寿命が終わってるんです
なぜなら十七回しかね
十七刹那しかいませんから
まあ大体心に情報が入ったのは刹那の二番目か三番目か四番目あたりなんですね
これで計算してみるとサンパティッチェのサンティーラナ・ゴッタパナでしょ
そこで三つ取っているし
あ じゃなくてパンチャドワラワッチャン・チャクニニャーナ・サンパティッチェ・サンティーラナ・ゴッタパナで五つ取ってるんですね
もし三番目の 安全で笑うのはそういうサンパティチェだっていうことだから
そうですね 三番目ぐらいの刹那で始めたならば
もう八番目の刹那にいるんですね
それで八番目の刹那に
この式が今八番目に立ち寄ってるんですね
もう八歳なんです 八歳なんです
そこで七回 即行するスタミナの心生まれるでしょうに
七回スタミナが心がスタミナ
いわゆる影響を受けると
もう八歳 また七足す十五歳になってるんですね
後で二つで死んじゃうんです
まあ一つでもう終わって
もう十七番目の刹那でもう死んじゃうんです
それは心のプロセスといって
認識の道なんですね いわゆる認識の
それもある一つだけ それは対象がこの目で見たものが生まれた
すぐ気づいた時に限るんです
で 私たちにわかるでしょうね
ずっとエネルギーは生まれるでしょうに
ものを見ると聞くと もう喋ると
何やったっても ずっとエネルギーはね
心の中にもすごい勢いで回転させてるでしょうに
で 何かなければもうできないということ
で まあわかるよ 例えば人がなんか眠たくてると
いきなり面白いもの見せたりすると
すぐもう目が覚めて もうそれに行っちゃうでしょうね
エネルギーが入っちゃうんです
だからこの即行心っていうのはポイントで
確定心またポイントで
で 人がもう確定しとるんで
この確定心っていうのは
この善も悪でもどうでもないんですけど
確定したところで どんな心がこの二九の中でどんな心に心を持って即行するか
スタミナになるかということはもう決めちゃう
だから目に情報入っちゃったら
我々は怒りの心で即行するかもしれませんし
欲の心で即行するかもしれませんし
無智 自己本心で即行するかもしれませんし
例えばアビダルマの勉強を聞いて
ものすごく目が覚める人も
もう咲いてくる人もあって
覚める人もあるかもしれない
どのように届くかっていうことは別に
だからそれ対象の受け入れ方なんですね
授業の受け入れ方 授業はある角度で受け入れると
耳から入ると心はすごいすごく勢いで回転するか
あるいは他の態度で授業を聞きちゃうと
心はエネルギーが消えちゃって
睡眠昏睡睡眠状態に落ち込んで寝てしまうかという
どっちかになってしまっちゃうんです
それは確定心で決めちゃうんです
ですから 例えば花を見たら
ああ 綺麗な花だと思ったら欲の心
あるいは嫌だなと こんなところで花があってと思っちゃったら
怒りの心と あるいは仏教の信者さんが花を見たら
綺麗な花だったら これ仏像の前で仏塔の前で供えておけばいいでしょうとかね
思っちゃったらもう善心でとかね
あるいは仏教でなくても
この花を持って悩んでる
なんとか誰かにあげちゃったら
その人いくらか心清らかに明るくなるだろうと思っちゃうと
ああ 綺麗な花だ いいなと思うんじゃなくて
この花持ってけばさ あの人なんとか明るくなるだろうと思っちゃうと
それが善心なんですね
ですから その瞬間でなんとか即行心が生まれる
だからこの即行心こそエネルギーの心で
スタミナの心で それは全部善悪選択可かなんです
はい  この間も聞いたんですけど
もう一回聞きたいんですけど
サンパティッチャとサンティーラナとそれから至正円
それは善意軸と不善意軸とありますよね
今のこのプロセスっていうのも順番でいくと
まず五蘊がこう切れちゃって
五門一手が働いて で 原意識から始まりますよね
原意識には不善意軸と善意軸とあるじゃないですか
クサラとアクサラと で
例えばアクサラの不善の原意識で始まったら
サンパティッチャもサンティーラナもこれもそのまま不善になるんですか？そして断定して全部不善意軸になったりはしないんですね
最後の至正円もやっぱり同じように
至正？ 至正円は  ただアラハンな
それはそれからの はいはい
その辺はほら 種類あるやつは
それはセット一つで  クサラだったら最後までこの流れで断定しないでクサラのままクサラのままいきます
うん で もう一つあと 生まれる時
決勝 部分心が 我々の場合は善意軸で生まれてるんですよね
タチサンは スッタラニパータで生まれてるんですけど
この今の認識のこの流れっていうのは
今やってるこの認識の間で使われてるサンパティッチャとサンニャーナっていうのがやっぱりサラ・ヴィパーカかアサラ・ヴィパーカですよね
それは根本は禅なんだけども
その認識で使われるこういう両住心とかは不戦五箇条にあるわけですよね
我々は不戦依軸も出るし
禅依軸両方解決できるんですよね
そこで面白いポイントは
そういうとこはもう法則だから決まってるんですね
で 不戦依軸の隨道心やら覚定心やら生まれるのだと
全部不戦依軸で決まっちゃうし
着鼻那那不戦依軸だったら不戦依軸で全部セット不戦依軸になっちゃう
でもポイントはこの即行心なんです
即行心 例えば不戦依軸で原識も生まれて
類住心も不戦依軸で隨道
類住心も隨道心も不戦依軸で
覚定心も不戦依軸でしたと
じゃあだったら即行心も不戦だよとはならないんですね
即行心してみれば もうまたいいように取るか悪いように取るかという
やっぱりそこら辺がすごい変わっちゃうんですね
ラッダッパッチャヤってあるじゃないですか
縁  縁に寄れてっていうことでラッダッパッチャヤって
これ注釈っていうか 日本語の訳の本にはよりぞ話からって書いてあるんですけど
それが縁になると書いてあるんですけど
どこでしたっけ？ 日本語の方ですか
日本語で誰がこれ注釈したのかわかんないんですけど
どこら辺ですか？ページは
98ページの太い字の日本語のところで 29
の即行心の中 何者かが
変わり者はないんですけど
それについて日本語でいろいろと書いてある
こっちが あ こっちはパーリ語でヤンケンチラッダッパッチャンゲーボーイエナサッタクカトゥンジャワティ
まあなんか適当な即行心が一つ7回生まれたという意味なんですね
適当と言ったっても その時の因縁によって因縁関係によってもう何かになるんだと
その縁っていうのはどんな縁が起こるんですか？ そこはもう最後に説明します
それはすごくあの 一応どこかで私は言ったんですね
この因果法則の場合は
この 2つの立場があるんですね
で 主観的な立場と客観的な立場というね
で もう忘れちゃったんだけど
これすごい難しい この存在の
で まあ例で言うと 私は一生懸命頑張って勉強するんだと
で 私は一生懸命頑張って勉強するんだから
私の頭が良かったんだというと
それはあくまでも主観的な私の努力だけ考えてしゃべることなんですね
でも 私の頭が良くなった結果が
単なる私の努力だけで成り立ってるわけじゃないんです
それはありとあらゆる外からの因縁もあるんですね
いい先生が一生懸命教えたとか
母親が一生懸命いい美味しいものを作ってくれたとか
父親が必要なものを買ってくれたとかね
そういう全部揃ったところで
私の頭が良くなったという結果が出てくるんですね
ですから こういう私が勉強しなきゃもう全然頭が良くならないし
ですから あなたの頭が良くなったのはあなたが勉強したんだからと言いますけど
じゃあ私が頑張ったんだから頭が良くなるかというと
そうでもないんですね
やっぱりまた自分でコントロールできない因縁もありますし
自分でコントロールできる因縁もありますし
その両方を合わせたところで結果が出てくるものです
ですから 私たちの希望通りに結果っていうのはありえないんです
オリンピックと同じで
オリンピック金メダル取るぞといって
個人の選手がいくら頑張っても必ずそのメダルを取れるということは決まってない
それにその個人選手に全くコントロールできない外の因縁もあるんですね
ですから そこで結果が決めちゃうんですね
その中で仏教でちょっと重点を置くんですね
個人のところに 自分の努力に
なぜならばそれは大事な決まり手なんですね
いくら母親が美味しいものを作ってくれても
父親が必要な勉強に必要な道具全部揃ってあげた